oh hi name is Andy Oh Robin nice to meet  you  all right so the first TV I'm not sure  you guys over here it's one of our newer  models are you seeing a trailer it's  playing in regular 1080p right now I'm  going to switch it to 4k which is the  new technology well what's the biggest  difference that you see a like enhanced  more have you  it almost looks realistic right yeah  yeah I have to reference remote so we'll  be right back in the little did that one  a picture oh my god  [Applause]  what do you think about the picture  quality so she's gonna be mad she looks  like she's gonna jump out Wow  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  there once was a girl no one dare speak  her name and death she seeks vengeance  for life filled with pain once you see  her story  you have seven days for it because she  does not forget and she does not forgive  what are you offer we gotta get out I  keep thinking about this story there's  this video